Hello everybody, this is Angie and if you've had
thermography done at Conner's Clinic,
you will most likely speak to me about your report.
So this is a preview of what you can expect
when we go over your thermography results.
So we'll talk about what thermography is,
scheduling your thermography review,
so you'll want to make sure that you do that
after you have your thermography scan.
It's a 15 minute appointment with me.
I'll send you a Zoom link for the appointment.
We'll go over that in just a minute.
We'll talk about what's included on the report,
what the radiologist, what they base their findings on,
important information on the report,
we'll look at a sample report
and we'll also talk about next steps.
So thermography captures and records temperature variations
on the skin, which is the largest organ of the body.
The surface of the skin provides vital information
that is directly influenced by complex metabolic
and vascular activity below the surface of the skin.
These patterns of activity can vary
and intensity and distribution over each area of the body
and that's represented by images with variation in colors.
In looking at variations in skin temperature,
we can see asymmetric abnormal or suspicious thermal patterns.
These patterns may be recognized then by the interpreter
as abnormal physiology or function or they may not.
These findings may be able to contribute
then to the decision making process
regarding future therapy, maybe some additional testing
that you might want to have done
and possibly an eventual diagnosis.
Thermography itself is not a diagnostic tool
but it can give us hints about what may be going on.
If you haven't already done so,
you'll need to call the clinic to schedule
your thermography review appointment.
Again, this is about 15 minutes.
Prior to your thermography review,
you can look for an email from Connor's clinic.
I will send you the Zoom link inside of that email.
About five minutes before our appointment,
while you're on your PC or Mac,
you can click on the link in that email that I send you
to join the web conference.
This is what the body of the email will look like,
the list the time and date of our appointment
that I scheduled, that you scheduled,
and the link to click on,
if you've not downloaded Zoom to your device
prior to this appointment,
just ask you to click on this link about five minutes
before our appointment.
You may need to then download the app onto your computer,
which you'll just follow through some prompts
to download it onto your device
and then you'll be able to click
to be able to join in on our meeting.
And then you'll wanna just make sure
that your computer volume is turned up
so that you can hear me and I can hear you.
We won't see each other, but you will see my screen
that shows your report.
When you get your report,
it'll have all of the information
that you provided on your thermography intake form.
It'll contain the radiologist's interpretation
of the images and recommendations for next steps
if they are recommending any.
For breast scans,
each woman will receive a grading or classification
identifying what level of risk you're currently at.
The report also has an explanation of thermography
similar to what we just talked about.
A color scale and of course your thermography images.
So what are the findings based on?
You're based on your thermography intake information
that you provided on the form
of the Connors Clinic Thermography intake form.
Your diagnosis is included on that
as well as the health history that you provide on that form,
your clinical concerns, your family history
and of course findings are based on the images.
The radiologists that read these images
do not have, they're not privy to what we do here
at Connors Clinic with our patients.
They don't know about the findings with the exams
or the therapies or protocols.
So all they know is the thermography intake information
and your images.
When we take a look at a sample report in just a minute,
you'll see information that is highlighted.
This is my highlighting and I like to go in and look
just prior to our appointment.
I will go in and look at your thermography report
and your images and I'll go through
and I will highlight the things that I want
to make sure that I point out to you.
You'll wanna make sure to read the rest of your report
when we get done talking
and of course if you have any questions
about anything after that don't hesitate
to reach out to me.
And again, you will receive a grading classification
if you had a breast scan done.
So let's take a look at the report.
When we start our meeting I will have images up on one side
and your report up on the other side
so that I can be going over your images
while we look at your report.
Health history that you provided is located here.
The thermographic interpretation is here
and they typically start at the top of the body.
So the first section is the head and neck section
and the first thing that they mentioned
that I want to point out to patients when I see this
is hypothermia around the mouth.
When we see this unless a patient has just had dental
work done or know that they've had some irritation
to the gums or teeth.
When we see this hypothermia around the mouth
that is something we want to nip in the bud.
You can see on the report here that the radiologist
noted that this hypothermia is most likely consistent
with some degree of what might be subclinical dental,
periodontal irritation.
Many patients are asymptomatic.
They don't have any pain in their mouth
or know of any infection.
But this is one thing that we like about thermography
is it can give us hints as to what's going on in the body.
So we recommend when we see this our tooth
and gum oil.
It comes in a dropper bottle.
It's about 70% black cumin seed oil and 30% oregano oil.
And it's a good preventive.
A good antibacterial will help fight infection.
We don't want periodontal irritation,
inflammation to turn into periodontal disease
that can lead to other issues in the body with the heart.
And it can lead to cancers as well.
So that is common.
We may find that on your report as well.
Honest persons report, there's also increased activity
at the front of the neck, which the radiologist noted
might be suggestive of some degree of thyroid dysfunction
correlate clinically.
So what that means is you might want to have that checked out
and you can have that checked out with your doctor
with blood test that can do a thyroid workup
and see how your numbers look there.
You can also set up an appointment with us to chat about that.
We may be able to do kinesiology to test
and see if there is anything going on with the thyroid
or if that's coming up with kinesiology,
we can help address that as well.
Honest persons report, there are no findings
to indicate significant carotid artery dysfunction,
but there is a slight increase at the base
of the right carotid artery, which is this area here.
That might be suggestive or be related
to systemic inflammation or elevated CRP levels.
CRP stands for C-reactive protein,
that's an inflammatory marker.
So this is not uncommon in inflammation,
systemic inflammation often leads to disease.
So this is not uncommon to see with our patients that come in.
And then in the breast section, this person
does have some slight areas of thermic and hyperthermic activity
to the central and peripheral regions of both breasts.
So centrally located throughout this area here
and to the sides, some slight hyperthermia here.
And they do not appear suspicious, but should be monitored.
By lateral underarm hyperthermia,
they can tell by the patterns that this is consistent
with lymphatic congestion.
For our patients that have come into the clinic
with our full program, our full plan patients,
you spent two days here, and we on day two
went over your three-ring binder
and talked about some home exercises.
One of those sheets talks about lymphatic exercises.
So this is where I would probably refer patients
to that sheet if we haven't already talked about it
just to revisit that.
And I would suggest that the patient continues
or starts to do one or more of those lymphatic exercises
to help keep lymph moving.
In the breast section, if it's a good scan,
you'll see words like this that the study is suitable
to be archived and compared with a repeat study in three months.
So the repeat study in three months gives us a comparison.
So we have these first set of images
and in three months when you come back
for your follow-up scan or your baseline scan,
they will compare the images from that scan
to the original scan and be able to then give a recommendation
as to whether or not you need to have
some further monitoring done on a more regular basis
or if things are changing, if they notice
that patterns are changing or if hypothermia is increasing
or maybe there's some vascular patterns
that indicate there may be some developing pathology,
they'll be able to note that on the three month baseline scan
and if not, then if things look just like this
and don't appear to be changing,
then typically after that baseline scan
unless a woman feels any additional lumps
or starts having any dimpling of the scan
or some other symptoms, it's okay typically to wait
and then have tests done, another scan done in about a year.
One other thing that I notice a lot in the thermography reports
is something like this indicates some degree of
or maybe indicative of or, you know,
and fervidge like that so they can't say specifically
what these thermal patterns are, they can only say that
this is what it looks like to us, it could be this,
it could be that so, and then again they may recommend
that you get it checked out further.
Many times we see this as well.
hypothermia consistent with myofacial inflammation,
lymphatic congestion and or muscular tension.
That is very common to see on thermography reports.
Myofascial inflammation refers to inflammation
of the connective tissue.
Connective tissue is weaved all throughout our bodies
from head to toe and we see this quite a bit.
Lymphatic congestion again, just want to point
to those lymphatic exercises again
and then muscular tension.
We all carry some degree of muscular tension.
So if we see a lot of that scattered throughout the report,
I may suggest that the patient does some relaxation techniques,
get some massage, something to help relax.
A hot tub, you may soak in some ebbs and salts would be good.
In the abdomen, they mention here that there is some
hyperthermic activity around the belly button area
which may indicate some element of gastrointestinal
autonomic neural activity and they're
suggesting a clinical evaluation for their investigation
to find out what these patterns might be correlated with
to tie them together with any symptoms.
And then on the report, there is always a discussion section
which typically recaps some of the things
that are important on the report and then a follow-up.
And all initial breast scans will say something like this
that follow-up breast imaging is recommended in three months
to establish a baseline before continuing
with annual comparative studies.
And here is where the classification or the grade is listed.
Each breast will have its own.
And in this case, the grading is at low risk for both left
and right breast.
There is a classification key here,
so a patient can read more about their grade.
As you scroll down your report, you'll
see information about their procedure, protocols,
what normal findings and abnormal findings consist of.
So you can use this information when you're talking
with us or with your other practitioners
for their testing may be suggested.
And thermography is especially with breast health.
It's good to monitor over time.
If desired, of course, you can set up an appointment with us
to talk about anything that is found on your thermography imaging
report that you might want to have checked out further.
You can talk about that.
We may be able to do some kinesiology testing
to see if it comes up with kinesiology.
And repeat, full body scans are not typically done,
but we do repeat breast scans.
We can monitor breast health over time,
but there are just too many things in the body that could change.
And breast health is what we really want to monitor.
We can, you know, if you wanted to have a whole upper body
and breast scan done to see if the hypothermia around your mouth
has decreased because you've been using the tooth and gum oil.
If you want to just satisfy your curiosity that way,
we certainly could, but it isn't necessary.
So we do repeat breast scans only typically.
And then when we are done talking over our Zoom appointment,
I will be sure to email your report to you
so that you have a copy of it.
So I thank you very much for listening,
and I hope that this preview has been helpful for you,
and I'm sure I will talk to you soon.
Thank you.